– Warum werden diese Fahrräder
eigentlich nicht mehr gebaut?
– Die Räder werden nicht mehr gebaut,
weil es die Firma nicht mehr gibt.
Hierher!
– Aber diese …
Klapp… Klappräder waren
doch sehr beliebt?
– Ja, in der DDR.
Aber nach der Wende
wurden viele Firmen in der
ehemaligen DDR geschlossen.
– Was bedeutet „Wende“?
– So nennt man die Zeit der
Wiedervereinigung.
Das war die Zeit, als aus Ostdeutschland
und Westdeutschland ein Land wurde.
– Okay. Aber warum mussten diese Firmen
schließen? Das versteh ich nicht.
– Ostdeutschland und Westdeutschland
waren nicht nur geteilt.
Es waren zwei total
unterschiedliche Länder
mit völlig verschiedenen
politischen Systemen.
– Und unterschiedlichen Währungen, und
die Menschen in der DDR konnten nicht
so einfach ihre Verwandten oder Freunde im
Westen besuchen oder in andere
westliche Länder reisen so wie heute.
Das weiß ich ja alles.
– Ja, und irgendwann hatten viele
Ostdeutsche genug von der DDR
und haben für mehr Freiheit demonstriert.
Und als die Grenze dann
endlich weg war,
da gab es viele Produkte aus der
ehemaligen DDR auch nicht mehr.
– Aber die Produkte waren ja
nicht schlecht?
– Nein. Aber die Menschen wollten
eben Veränderung. So!
Und jetzt bringen wir das Rad mal
wieder so richtig auf Vordermann.